今日大家定了一个题目
就是洪水重临
不知道这个题目你会想起什么呢?
不知道你会不会想起
几年前国家地理杂志
曾经有一个纪录片
英文叫做Before the Flood
中文就译做洪水来临前
也都是说到关注气候转变
今天就不是电影欣赏会
但这个纪录片其实在YouTube里面你找得到的了
今天订这个题目都很合适的
为什么呢?因为你知道两三个礼拜前
在英国有这个气候的高峰会
我想大家都没有去过中间那里示威
曾经最近有一个调查的
显示有四分三的年轻人
对于将来是充满了恐惧的
原因是气候变化
很多年轻人
对前景充满迷茫,因为前面似乎不确定
洪水来临
我记得在2009年的时候曾经有一个新闻
印度洋岛角马尔代夫
内阁开会专门走到海底
即係帶著啲潛水器具喺海底度開呢個內閣會議
點解呢?
佢哋想引起全球嘅關注,國際嘅關注呢
如果唔理會氣候嘅轉變,呢度海水不斷升高呢
咁佢哋嘅國家呢就會喺海底啦咁樣
咁又好似呢一度呢就係所羅門群島啦
咁就喺太平洋,南太平洋嘅所羅門群島
咁呢个呢系一个嘅60分钟时事杂志嚟㗎
咁就访问当地嘅一个人
咁最上面呢幅图呢
睇见呢就系
呢个人
细过时候呢
咁就
去呢度玩嘅经常
咁但系依家呢
冇咗个岛啦
你见唔到个岛啦咁就
咁就啲水不断升高呢就好多陆地呢就被掩抹啦
咁另外顺带一提呢就喺你嘅
右下角呢幅图呢
都好有意思㗎
因为海水升高呢
原本那些植物呢,因为海水咸的嘛
那些植物呢就会死啦
那一会呢
我们都会再提这一点的
那些海水慢慢高,很多陆地就被淹没啦
你发觉不单止岛国的
那这里就是意大利的威尼斯
因为海水上升呢
近年经常都
水浸呀
不知道你有没有听过摩西计划呢
佢哋就係計劃起一啲嘅水閘呢就擋住啲海水咁樣
咁呢個就係19年嘅時候呢水浸嘅情況
後面嗰度橋呢好出名㗎
如果你去過呢個威尼斯人嘅酒店呢
喺外面都有個咁樣嘅橋係嘛
咁本來呢條係河嚟㗎
咁但係你水浸到呢就已經去到
商舖行人路啦咁你見到啲船喺度啦咁樣
咁唔單止19年嘅20年又浸
即係話近年呢好多時都水浸㗎
大家在这个纽西兰,不知道你有没有留意这个新闻,在你上面有一个国家就是印尼,印尼的首都就是耶加达,最近也都宣布搬它的首都,为什么呢?
因为耶加达在海边,因为海水高涨,经常都水浸,每次一下雨,一打风就水浸,原因就是因为第一天那里很多人,他们抽地下水,令到耶加达陆地下陷,向下降,再加上海水又升高,每年都浸得很厉害,所以决定搬去卡里曼丹岛。
其实影响着很多国家很多人的
比如在曼加拉
沿岸很多人都已经搬去
较北内陆的地方
这些就是
气候难民
因为海水不断升高
不单止海水升高的
这个画面如果你留意新闻你都了解
今年7月中国河南
因为年长豪雨
你见到这样的光景,浸了隧道,伤亡都很严重。
左手边下面这幅图就是当日浸了的地下铁路,
在地下铁路车厢里面浸到人的上身。
为什么会下大雨,会浸得这么厉害呢?
因为由于气候变暖,空气暖了,
空气里面能够保持的水就多了,
所以令到这些Torrential Rain一些的骤雨
下起来的时候很严重
有几个钟头就可能下了几天的雨
几天就可能下了一年的雨
认不认得这里是哪里呢
不认得吧
这里同样是7月
不过是纽西兰
下雨啦,经过了一个周末之后
下完雨之后的景况
所以不单止中国的
也不单止北半头
南半球都一样
几日前
留意新闻温哥华下雨下得很厉害
令温哥华和周围外界的交通断绝
因为很多公路被淹浸
很多桥
都冲断了
你看见右手边
就是火车轨
铁路
也冲坏了
你发觉不单止落骤雨会造成什么效果
近年如果你留意每一次打风你都会听到所谓风暴潮
风暴潮的意思就是因为由于打风的时候
风眼地方就是低气压
会将海水扯高
所以每次打风潮水就会高了
这个就叫风暴潮
这个就是05年的时候在美国
海水星高打完纽奥良之后的景况
所以不在乎你
城市是怎样
好似美国这样
你发觉一样水浸
刚才我提过
海水星高会令到沿岸的植物死
其实后来有人研究为什么Katrina会令到纽奥良有这么严重的水浸
当然一方面就是Katrina本身
风力比较强啦
另外有些个堤坝决堤啦
但亦都有个好紧要原因就因为呢
海水不断升高呢
令到沿岸好多的那些沼泽地方的植物就死了
以至到沿岸就
没有了一个缓冲的地带,没有了一个buffer zone
所以打风的时候呢
那些风啦,那些海浪呢
就直接冲击那个市区
这个就是
2005年Katrina的情况
这就是2012年,就是Hurricane Sandy
不知道你认不认识这是哪里,这里是纽约
在美国东岸
我值得一提,纽约其实在北纬40多度
Hurricane的意思是巨风
如果在香港的地方就叫做Typhoon
其实它正式的学名就叫Tropical Cyclone
即是热带的旋风
顾名思义说这些风全部都在热带地方发生
纽约在北纬四十几度
你可以看见现在全球暖化令到很多热带的灾害
例如打风打到很北似乎这是一个新常态
也一样如果你去过纽约你就知道地形
海水升高风暴潮
令到浸过了曼哈顿,即是Lower Manhattan
你知道其实纽约有一个名叫做
City Never Sleep,即是不会睡觉的城市
基本上在曼哈顿下城,是一个金融中心
24小时都是灯光火着的
因为那些
金融交易
原来很多金融机构的电脑就在地底
那次的水浸
损伤很严重
其实往后用了几年时间才慢慢恢复
同样也浸了这些地下铁
很多老鼠走了出来
仿佛帮城市清洗一下
你右手边这幅图
你很难想象平时人来往地铁站水浸
你看见那些潜水人员在搜救
这个是17年澳门台风天鸽吹袭
由于这个风暴潮海水倒灌
令到市区的情况这样
这次的伤亡都是严重的
其实香港的照片我没有放出来
你发觉每一年
一打风
近年17年有天甲18年有山竹
你发觉沿岸的地方无论将军澳
横花村一些低一些的地方
沿岸就经常被海浪侵袭
讲到这里
我想起一节圣经在路加福音21章
圣经里面讲到将来主回来之前世界的景况
其中有一句这样的说话
地上的邦国也有困苦
因海中波浪的响声就慌慌不定
圣经也提及我们末后的日子
其中一个灾害就仿佛就是海中的波浪
咁頭先我哋有睇過呢個海水嘅升高啦即係風暴潮啦咁樣咁其實我最先留意呢一節聖經呢就係04年
就係因為南亞海嘯
咁當然仲有後嚟2011年嘅東日本大地震引發嘅海嘯啦
咁呢啲都好似話畀我哋知道呢
呢一個情況因海中嘅波浪呢
人就慌慌不定啦咁樣
讲到这里,我想起圣经里面特别记载了一件事
主耶稣在地上的时候,曾经帮门徒在加利利海
突然间遇见大风浪,门徒其中有一些是渔夫来的,都见过风浪
但是因为风浪很大,甚至他们觉得没有命了
但是主就在船尾里睡着了,他们叫醒主,他就说主下没有命了
主起身之后,就斥责风浪,就使风浪平静了
我觉得圣经里面记载的这件事都很有意思
一方面就是你看见主耶稣
他真是能够搭救我们脱离危险
另外一方面也说,主能够平静风浪
无论在你人生中
遇到什么艰难
打击,有什么波浪
主都能够平静一切风浪
如果今天有些基督徒的朋友邀请你来
其实基督徒的朋友都很乐意跟你分享他人生中主要是如何帮助他平静他人生的风浪
好了,考考大家一个问题
在这杯水里面就装满了冰,也装满了水,水就去到杯口了
隔一段时间之后,当冰融,问大家一个问题,到底水会不会流出杯外面呢?
不会。
不会啊?真是很厉害。
其实我想说什么呢?水是很特别的一样东西,不单止说它的结构,因为H2O,H就是Hydrogen,你知道本身可以燃烧,O就是Oxygen,即氧气,本身能够助燃的。
但竟然呢
氫氣加上氧氣變成水就可以能夠救火
另外還有一樣特別,所有的東西都是熱脹冷縮
當溫度越低的時候,水的體積就越縮
但很奇怪
當到攝氏4度的時候
體積
就去到最細
就不再縮了
到3度2度1度,到0度結冰的時候,體積就開始膨脹
所以密度反而会降低了
因为密度低了,所以你发觉冰就浮在水上面了
所以发觉冰是很特别的
为什么?我觉得是神的怜悯
你想想如果水变成冰的时候,密度高就沉在水底
所有海里面的生物就死了
你想象一下,等于人走过个淫蜂,淫蜂一跌下来就死了
但你发觉好得意,当水结冰的时候,体积反而会膨胀,密度会减低,以致会浮在水里面。
还有一样东西很特别,就是什么呢?你看到冰是否很大?
但是当冰变成水的时候,它的体积反而会缩小,因为刚才说过,冰结冰的时候体积大了,变成水的时候体积就会缩小。
而它缩小了的体积正好就是它突出水面的这个volume
所以有些人就说你见到冰山你好走啦
其实你见到冰山突出水面的部分大约是11%左右
在水底里面有89%
所以有九成的冰山在水底下面
所以你离远见到冰山的时候
其实可能你都水底的冰可能很接近都未定
原来在海洋上面,在水上面的冰不会令到海水升高的,只会令到北极熊找不到落脚的地方,因为冰溶解,可能要去很远的地方才找到落脚的地方。
即是说令到海水升高呢
其实最主要呢就是陆地上的冰
通常人们说就是什么呢
就是格陵兰和南极洲了
这里有一个新闻
就在今年八月
你觉得很特别的
就在格陵兰就第一次下雨
我都不以为然
我即时有个感觉就是什么呢
难道格陵兰以前没有下过雨
你觉得为什么这个会出现在头条里面呢?
其实你想一想,格陵兰在加拿大东边很北的嘛,
其实它不应该下雨的,它应该下雪的,你明白吗?
所以从格陵兰第一次记录下雨,就反映出温度升高了,
而在你右手边,你看见那些狗拖着雪橇,
它就不是在水面上面走,而是因为在那些冰的表层,
表层溶解得好厉害呀
所以你咁影埋去
就好似啲狗呢
喺水面上行
咁其实呢就係在Greenland
即係格陵兰
表面嘅冰溶解嘅情况
有人计过啦如果格陵兰嘅冰溶解呢
海水大约升高廿几尺啦,大约两层楼
咁两层楼
都成廿几尺都好高喎,唔知大家住嘅地方近唔近海边啦
唔知大家
住喺几楼啦
但如果南极的水,南极的冰溶解又怎样呢?
南极的冰是格陵兰的九倍
即是说如果南极的冰和格陵兰的冰一起溶解的话
全世界的海水的高度就会升高到21、22层楼左右
你们想听听情景吗?
这个只不过是由于陆地的冰溶解令到海水升高
其实当温度高的时候还有一个因素还有一个影响是很大的
就是因为温度高海水膨胀
海水膨胀而令到海面升高这个是其实情况是很严重的
今年的2月有一个新闻
就是俄罗斯首次有破冰船能够横越
北冰洋以前一些没办法穿过的航道
这个是讲出什么呢
这个就讲出北冰洋北极
那些冰薄了很多
可能你说
不怕你刚刚说完
你说北极
在海上的冰用了是不会影响海水高度的
但是呢
有其他的影响
近年你有没有经常听到热浪
今年六月就试过了
今年6月试过热浪侵袭加拿大,加拿大很北的
温哥华是北纬50度的地方
但想想温哥华
隔离的卡尔加里
卡尔加里
摄氏40几度
可能你会觉得很奇怪
为什么这么北会有热浪呢?如果你留意下近年的热浪
经常都是由于一个情况,所谓叫做Heat Doom
中文语语叫热盖
一个覆盖的盖
想象下你煲东西煲水
有盖盖没有盖盖
是不是不同
盖盖是否很快就滚了
因为那些蒸汽走不到
蒸汽走不到
很快就滚了
情况就一样
因为这幅图你看见
你看不看见这里有一个叫jetstream
高空的高速气流
它就是形成一个高气压
就令到下面嗰啲空气呢
佢虽然不热
但系散不到
冇办法走到
就好似盖咗盖咁样
就令到好短时间里面呢
嗰啲空气呢
就加热得好快
所以你諗下去到北纬50几度
都能够录到摄氏40几度喎
其实呢个系好夸张
好啦
不过我想你留意
我唔系想介绍嗰个HeatDoom
亦都介绍多个字啦
其实呢一个咁样嘅气流嘅现象呢
叫做Omega Block
因为它的形状好像希腊文的Omega的字母
其实我想你留意高空气流Jetstream的影响
你发觉因为它的摆动
令到热空气走不到就有Heat Doom, Heat Wave
同样地由于这样的摆动
你看见就令到北极里面的寒流
那些极地的漩涡就向南
有些地方就伸展得更加难
所以近年你听见经常好多新闻就是
有好多地方有热浪
同时
又有好多地方
是破纪录的低温
甚至试过
有一次
多伦多
陆地的温度比起北极都还要低
为什么呢
就是因为这样的现象
可能你会问一个问题
为什么这Jetstream会这样摆动呢
其实这Jetstream的摆动的原因
就是因为它变弱了
因为它变弱了,因为它减慢了
你想像一下,好像一条河
去到下游的地方,去到平原的地方
它的速度是不是慢了,因为没有那么斜
为了向前走,它是不是会摆动
那条河是不是会摆动,meandering
其实同样的情况
因为Jetstream
它减弱了,减慢了
就令到它摆动,因为这样的摆动
令到刚才我讲的那些热浪又或者那些北极寒流的侵袭是更加的频繁
好了,那你会问一问题,为什么会减弱了呢?
其实这个就证明了一样东西,就是北极暖了很多
因为原来北极的温度和周围的温度的相差
如果它相差越大,因为周围流入北极的空气的速度不是快,Jetstream就强
而当北极温度升高之后,温差低了,就令到这Jetstream就减弱了。
其实有研究显示,全球的温度转变不是一致的,而在北极里面,温度的升高是周围地方的4倍。
即是说北极的地方是暖得更加快的。
可能你会问一个问题,就是为何会暖得这么快呢?
其中一个很主要原因是西伯利亚大火
其实这场火烧了好几年了,其实2021世纪最大的火
就是今年在西伯利亚在俄罗斯烧着的大火
其实这个火场的面积比起北美洲
加州、加拿大加起来的山火
加上欧洲、加上土耳其的山火,面积更要大
这个就在高空上面影到去
西伯利亚火警的情况,你发觉是不是很多地方都没有烟?
为什么这么奇怪?为什么我看不到火就是只有烟的?
原来在西伯利亚里面,在北极圈里面的火是很特别的
这个火有个名叫做Zombie fire,即是说丧尸火,顾名思义知道什么意思吗?
又不可以盖上它,又消灭不了它
为什么会这样?因为北极圈里面低温
很多那些植物死了之后呢
没有分解
所以在泥土下面有很多有机的物质
而当有火警发生的时候有时这些火
就会烧到落地底
烧到落地底的时候
你发觉就
你没办法救熄
但有机会呢就会烧上去
地面
所以这场火其实烧了好几年
有没有影响呢
这个就是在地面在卫星图片上面影到的
你看见是不是很多火头
其实地底下面是烧紧的
但一有机会就冒出地面了
曼山片野都是冒烟就是这样的情况
你说西伯利亚大火
北极圈大火有什么影响呢
上年有一个这样的新闻
你见到上面那幅图那条河是不是染到红了
不是因为流血
而是因为
漏油
你知道北极圈的地
叫Permafox,即是那些积了很多冰,结冰了
上面有很多的炼油设施,有很多油库
但是随着北极圈的温度升高,这些冰溶解
令到很多炼油的设施,譬如油库下陷,就漏油
这个就是上年五月的时候,漏油的情况,是一个生态灾难
如果你去西伯利亚近年经常都会见到这些坑
你见到这些人你就会体会这些坑是多么大
为什么会有这么大的坑呢?
谁有那么多时间挖坑呢?其实不是挖出来的
就是因为地图就暖了,冰溶解
就释出了困在地里面的甲烷
而甲烷呢
呢个你睇见呢
好似有个bubble咁样
即系在泥土下面呢
在啲植坯下面呢
有一啲甲烷嘅气体
有时呢佢就会发生爆炸
咁就造成头先你睇到嘅嗰啲坑啦
咁喺呢啲水下面嗰啲嘅bubble呢
全部都系methane嚟㗎
有啲人如果你在网上搵到啲照片呢
就有啲人喺度玩
就喺啲冰嗰度呢
做个窿跟住点火咁樣
咁其实呢甲烷
作为这个温室气体呢
其实methane的影响比二氧化碳还要高20倍
即是同样体积的二氧化碳对温度的影响
如果是换上一张甲烷,它的影响是20倍
所以有人这样研究过了
他说什么呢?
他说一旦西伯利亚的甲烷释出来
那个影响就相等于全球的二氧化碳排放的总和的影响
呢个好大慨危机
另外想起圣经里面
另外一句话
喺启示录里面讲到将来灾难嘅日子里面
天使将碗倒喺日头
日头就能够用火烧人
现在有时有啲地方都热到成40几度啦, 刚才讲过温哥华
Calgary
另外有啲地方热到50几度都有
咁头先如果我讲到呢嗰啲methane咁样释出嚟呢
其实对于全球的温度
影响可以变得很快
变得很急促
所以如果你问我
你说日头敲人
我觉得这个不是
一些天方夜谭
其实现在已经有迹象让我们看见
全球的暖化
其实可以
变得很快
变得很恶劣
在这幅图里面让我们看见
山林大火的情况
刚才我们有说过西伯利亚的大火
你看到了
这里你也看到有几场火的
这一场就是亚马逊森林
这里就是非洲刚果盆地
这里就是印尼婆罗洲
都是热带地方
都是一些 tropical rainforest
热带雨林区
都是烧得很严重
西伯利亚的火刚才我们说过了
那亚马逊森林又怎样呢
其实亚马逊森林的火很多是人放的
有些就是他斩树木,我们拿木材
更多就是他烧了树林之后就用来养牛
为什么会这样呢?
因为牛的market price,即牛的价值价高
能够卖到多些钱
所以发觉气候峰会里面其中一个主题
就是提供一些资助给一些国家
譬如巴西这样的
就令到它禁止人去砍伐亚马逊森林
但其实呢
我不知现在会不会是比较为时已晚
为什么呢
近年有很多研究
就显示亚马逊森林是全球最大的
热带雨林区
可以说是地球的第1个肺
但是呢
有些研究显示
亚马逊森林的碳排放
现在已经超出它的碳吸收
一般来说
一个雨林区,当有阳光的时候,有光合作用,它就会吸入大气层里面的二氧化碳,就成为它那些树木那些的碳,这个就是所谓碳吸收。
但是为什么碳排放更多呢?一方面就是当它着火之后,是不是释出很多二氧化碳?另外还有排出很多碳的微粒。
其实近几年的趋势,其实亚马逊森林的碳排放比碳吸收已经超出了
其实我想起这些日子是否经常都有冠状病毒,引起的问题就是肺炎
肺炎就是呼吸不到,似乎地球都患了肺炎
另外还有就是刚才我讲过这个非洲的刚果盆地
这个可以说是全世界第二个肺
也是一个热带雨林区
在你的右手边看到两幅照片
你可以看到其实那些救火设施是很落后的
大火怎么救呢?
就是靠那些东西喷一下喷一下
好像水枪那样怎么救呢?
但是那些火是怎么来的呢?
其实那些火是人刻意放的
因为在非洲地方呢
如果要得到粮食呢就要耕种
咁点样耕种呢
佢就会用一种方法叫火耕
即是说呢烧了一个树林
咁就有个范围呢
那些枯叶都可以帮助佢好似肥料咁样啦
咁就会种野
咁如果种咗几年之后呢
嗰个地方呢就会因为好多杂草生
咁于是嗰啲人呢就会搬去第二度再烧个另一个地方
咁原先嗰个地方呢
就比佢
慢慢恢復生育植物
其實以前一直都是這樣運作的
這種火耕的運作
叫刀耕火種
為什麼現在一發不可收拾呢
其實就引申到一個問題
因為人多了
因為人口多了
那些棄置的地方沒有時間
沒有足夠時間讓它恢復
因為也多了人要吃東西
所以他們只有燒
就没有时间给那些树林恢复
就令到全球的第二个肺也都引发肺炎
这个就是第二个问题
就是近这100年里面
全世界的人口急速的增长
从这幅图里面看见
在1930年全世界有20亿人
但是去到今年,已经是11月尾了
那全球的人口已经有79亿了
根据推算,虽然有疫情
但可能去到明年的年尾
全世界的人口已经突破会超过80亿
即是说由20亿
到80亿
其实头尾都不够100年
这是一个很严重的问题
因为人口多了的时候
地球的资源是有限的
哪些地方的人口增加得特别厉害呢
就是非洲
所以也有人估计
几年后
全世界最大的城市不是纽约,不是东京,而是在尼日利亚的一个地方叫做拉高斯，Lagos。
非洲是人口增长得很快的地方,另外就是中东的地方。
另外当然还有印度,中国13亿人,其实老化得很快。
所以近年开放了一孩政策,鼓励人生,监人生,生两三个孩子
当人多的时候,有些是没办法的
所以你发觉气候峰会竟然没有接触到这个问题
反而就是倚靠碳排放国家,碳排放国家最大的就是中国,第二就是印度
两个都是过十亿人口的国家
但你知道这些承诺都是口头的
为什么呢?因为例如上个月
你看见中国是不是在东北有电荒
又过冬了又没有电了
都不知道这些暖气怎么来怎么搞
而在中国发电很多时候是烧煤的
人多又闹电荒
不要说那些生产是需要电力了
而发电它主要是烧煤
咁佢點樣能夠答應減排呢
所以其實呢
即係呢個係一個好大問題咁而隔離嘅右手邊呢幅圖呢
就有多人關注所謂叫地球嘅carrying capacity
即係話到底地球
佢嘅面積佢嘅資源能夠支持幾多人呢
近啲幾十年好多人研究啦咁
最多科學家有個共識就係咩呢就係全球嘅
資源呢能夠供應到80億人
但别忘记由于各样的天灾气候的转变
旱灾我们今天都没有提
其实你可以想象地球是一个平衡
有些地方下雨下得那么紧要的时候
你应该也想象到有些地方是很厉害的干
加州就是一个例子
这些灾害同时也会降低了地球的carrying capacity
所以其实这个是一个都不知道怎么解决
所以说到这里我就想起这架船,这架Titanic,Titanic沉就因为它撞冰山,话说当年就是当它撞冰山的时候,船长就立刻开会,因为它处理行,设计师在那里,船主也在那里,就走在一起,
咁佢檢視咗之後呢發覺船頭嘅地方呢就第一個第二個第三個第四個第五個compartment即係個船艙呢入水呀
嗰個設計師就好緊張呀
因為個船佢設計㗎嘛
咁個船長話
入水可唔可以用泵去泵呢咁樣
大家你眼望我眼已經知道發生咩事呀
用泵泵水呢只能夠buy time
幾分鐘
點解呢
因為架船
三个舱四个舱漏水,还可以浮在水里,
但是如果五个舱就没有办法浮了。
那个船主就问了,
船主说怎么可能呢?
处女航第一次。
那个设计师就说了,
这架船是钢铁造的,
它会沉。
It's just a mathematical certainty,
即是一个数学的肯定来的。
其实当你看见刚才这样的情况呢,
是很困难的。
我想起几年前,戈尔当他落任美国副总统后关注全球气候转变
拍了一个电视剧,叫做Inconvenience True
中文是香港译作什么?绝望真相
我觉得说到这里,真的没有希望
可能你说全球攜手,减碳排放
其实刚才也提过,起码他忽略了一个很大的问题
就是人口的问题
再说轮流攜手减排的一个问题
所以为什么七成的年轻人
对于前面没有什么盼望
充满了恐惧
想到这里我觉得
如果真的没有盼望
我真的不知道跟大家分享什么好
但是很宝贵
原来圣经最后给我们有一句这样的说话
就是主耶稣说的
主耶稣他差遣他的使者
向教会证明什么呢?
下面有一句话,他说什么?
他说我就是明亮的晨星
原来当天越夜的时候就越黑,越冻
当他去到最冻的时候,临天光的时候
晨星就出现了
当人见到晨星的时候就知道很快天光了
主的意思是什么呢?
他就是给人盼望
当见到他的时候
天亮的时候就快到了
为什么呢?
因为主耶稣他已经应许过为我们预备地方
当我们预备好地方之后,他要回来提接一切信的人到他那里去
所以这个世界的景况
其实是预备人的心
让人知道
没有盼望
但是很宝贵
有主耶稣的人
他有一个活泼的盼望,就是主耶稣要回来
提接我们到他那里去
接着我会和大家分享一首诗歌
这首歌叫做主如明亮的神声
带给我们盼望、带给我们光亮
使我们在绝望中仍然能够看见远处的出路